yeah everyone turn on the red see like
if anyone
wants to play i'll i'll keep it off this
time so one of you guys can do it
okay sounds fair all right i also have
to like up my brightness a lot
he upped his brightness that sounds
cheaty
that does sound cheaty i mean if you're
the monster you have to or you literally
see nothing that's not i didn't even
follow brightness but that's the point
i didn't follow the brightness i
followed the radar not the [ __ ]
screams
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
oh my god oh my god how do you see what
do you see where do you work
it's very blurry it's blurry man
i am a bush man what's the point of
camouflage
go away go away go away go away go away
you don't want to be here oh all right
do i want to be here now no go away
where'd you go bush buddy
where are you at friend i can't see [ __ ]
just there's nothing here god i've i
found nothing there was nothing
i went through the whole goddamn map i'm
just going to lay down and die
i'm here i'm here i have no chance i'm
here
here i am i literally went through the
whole i'm over here
wait i went through the whole map i went
in multiple buildings i didn't find a
single thing
i'm here hey right here kill me i i
literally went through the whole map
and i couldn't wait is that actually
since you're not talking
to me anyway a little weird
well all right anyway
hey guys hey look oh wow it's a little
hey oh man are these your kids
they're lovely they're beautiful just
like
they're papa wow okay
why were they all silent creatures i
swear i went through the whole map
circled through multiple buildings found
nothing and i was like okay maybe they
got something in the car
maybe there's something there and i was
like not a thing
nothing left i have no idea how wade
phoned me
i my i thought the the creature would
have like no sight unless there's sound
and the sound there's almost no sight
anyway it's so blurry
it's so blurry what does sound do does
sound make it more clear
so on your mini-map it like gives you an
icon and then pretty much i would face
it
spam queue and just sprint at it because
i'm saying turning up the brightness
didn't do anything
yeah once every like you still kind of
and that gives you some clarity
but like the radio turned on the mice
squeaking like i kept running toward the
sounds and i could not find you at the
end mark yeah
well i was playing it like that i was
playing it like turning on sounds
throwing stones like throwing things
away from me and that seemed to work
especially like the the second thing the
mice also threw me off so i didn't know
what was a stone what was a mouse
squeaking what was the reason
because he is a mouse to squeak yeah the
squeaking as the mice really [ __ ] with
me because i could not figure out what
the hell that makes sense that makes
sense but it's really hard to see when
you're the rake it's really hard
literally you only can depend on sound
notifications and blips on your map
fair enough fair is fair
all right looks like bob's uh bob's a
man
okay okay i run faster when the escape
way is open
and i have a bear trap how did you throw
rocks i've got two bullet things
so he's probably coming straight for us
right off the bat so
your damn mechanical keyboard
[Music]
oh well that doesn't bode well okay but
i think if he's after him i can go
a little bit where is anything how am i
not finding anything
[Music]
oh you better run oh you're just hucking
rocks you're getting scared now
no no
don't be scared i already found jack i
let him go
we cool we cool
bro we so cool right now
i mean it's really [ __ ] hammering
down some noises oh you hopped off
oh i see i see what's going on
uh let's see this is where i just left
shawn i don't wanna i don't wanna ruin
his night oh hey
funny that you just came over here huh
literally the one spot huh
yeah well i actually there's like other
sounds i was listening to
i guess it's you yeah sounds yep i was
chucking rocks
all around me not here not this place
not where i am currently yeah
it turns out if you throw them in a
circle i can kind of figure out where
this sounds
no i wasn't throwing in a circle i was
throwing it over to the right
oh hold your leg use your flashbang okay
you're the toll for your life is a
flashback that's fair and i suppose
lastly big boy ah ooh
i can't see ah darn it ah gosh dang
i think you actually got away from me
okay i think he's gonna be busy over on
the other side for a bit
i think i'm on the complete opposite
side of where the car is my inventory
is full
i don't think that's near the car that's
fine though
oh this is rocks i bet they're coming
from this way
mark you gotta you gotta pick a
different trajectory for your rocks my
dude
[Music]
no come on stand in it
bob
this is so stupid your eyes are cool in
the dark though
well that's unfortunate for me what the
hell was with you and coming straight
for me when i'm being completely silent
well if you're talking to me i can't
hear you so i better run
yeah serpentine zigzag
through the bushes if i pee while i run
he'll never catch me
speed serpentine throw them
brambles this way
and then throw a rock perfect and i'm
free
oh hi well
look at rock can you guys hear me yeah
yeah you were
you were freaking the [ __ ] out a little
bit i can't hear
i can't hear anyone else so i'm just
like yeah talking to myself but i
heard you interacting with mark and sean
early on but then uh whenever you killed
me
uh you were just kind of like one
framing it in game you're just kind of
teleporting oh i see
i was i stopped hearing you i could i
can't find the goddamn car i
i've have i've had this gas can okay
freaking battery forever
i've been doing a whole bit about being
your supervisor and chasing you around
and you better find the car
i'm gonna have to reprimand you you
might as well reprimand me i oh there it
is all right put him in there all right
is shawn dead no no i let him go
i'm alive i got i caught all three as
wade you're i thought you had a
flashbang still wait sorry
he'll go ahead and escape it'll be fine
i took mark's flashbang at some point
yeah bob
what did you see or hear to come
straight for me because i swear
i was like dead silent in the dark and
you you just like
gunned straight for me it was literally
an accident
i saw your rocks and i assumed that they
were all being thrown from the same
position
and i just took a guess at where no the
second time the second time
uh like when you were with that was that
was an accident because i was messing
with sean
and i was just like well let's go see if
mark's around because i heard he just i
got
one directly away from me i did get one
big sound queue
in that direction i don't know what it
was and so i just
sprinted away from where jack was and i
literally just ran into you
yeah i think you got like we have to put
on push to talk because it's like
if i go it triggers my my i think that
must be it yeah it's just going good
yeah
like that's it so i would recommend push
the doc anyway uh
you got me look at the car
oh my god talk to your body when you
died three minutes remaining hurry up
you got all the parts you need uh it
looks like it's missing a couple tires
i have a wheel it won't let me put it on
for some reason why select it select it
in your
your thing oh all you have is a one
wheel
i i put on another wheel and i have the
key now i am disappointed
so i was in the barn whenever bob was
terrorizing you like at the beginning of
the game
and i couldn't really move so i went to
leave and he was at that entrance like
terrorizing mark it's like okay i'll go
the other way and then he ran around he
was like okay i guess i'll stay here
i thought i hurt you
go push to talk if we're just gonna do
one more with me as monster
i would recommend pushduck my chat is
saying mark
sean threw a rock directly at you as
well
did i i don't think so i
threw it right directly at all i
definitely saw one sound cue
no i was i was throwing at sean just
because i was like yeah let's
let's just see if i can throw him under
the bus for this one
i i was just throwing rocks in random
directions if it was that america i
don't think i
did it on purpose me throwing at you was
definitely on purpose
oh that is blurry
oh that is blurry okay jump
interesting interesting okay
no blips it might have been the voices
or maybe they're talking who knows god
it's blurry
ah it's all blurry it's a tree it's
blurry
a lot of blurs oh those are in
very different places hmm
this is fascinating
this is kind of cool neato
oh crows crows got me
interesting hello
is someone here
hello
someone in the house hello
i'm looking in the windows hard to see
i heard a dog whistle
hello hello
hello
hi hey how's it going i could see your
light
how scary was that i don't know i don't
know what this is either
oh the storm makes it so that i can't
hear anyone
oh fascinating is that just like a
random thing
that'd be cool if that's just like
random too much
noise that's cool i like that i really
like that actually
i like the impediment of the rain the
rain is super cool
it's gotta be random though oh rain's
over
finally
hello
oh it's right here oh hello who's there
a hair voice let's speak up again it was
such a lovely voice
hello
hello hello
hello hi
a word of advice maybe turn off your
flashlight next time
see ya later this is dope this is fun
i always love playing these games just
slightly silly
it's that damn radio in here
wasting power ow
who did that
hello
oh hey mark how's it going i could
good it's i'm yeah so listen
well like your eyes i haven't seen it
like that before so
i'll tot do you remember how this works
i will totally give up one of my friends
if you don't make me waste my flashbang
this is acceptable where is a friend
okay do you want me to lead you to them
or just tell you because i feel like
they might leave if they hear us coming
just tell me okay so behind you to your
right the path that the lights go down
that leads on the left of that there's
like a house
that leads past they just went to check
out that house because we hadn't we
hadn't looted there yet
even in the house with the radio on it
uh it was not on when i walked past it
earlier but
i think there's a radio in that
direction that i just came from with the
radio and the bear trap in it
you didn't count you came from the other
way i circled it all right
yeah you read the entire map oh are you
sassing
right now are you sassing me yeah i'm
sassing you right now
do it yeah do it
you're gross i hate you yeah you mixed
two of us
hello someone in here
someone in this house
that sounds like a bear trap
are you still there
i see you you don't
you're lucky i can't jump that high
so
oh hello
hi
man they got a lot of batteries my leg
was off that time
this is super fun i i think this would
be it needs some tweaks
to make it more uh more overall
interesting but uh
it's got some good stuff what did i hear
there was a big noise over here
was it in the house hello
is that you wade are you back in the
house
hello hey [ __ ] kill me dude
okay kill me there's a squeaky bear
there's a [ __ ] clown and i don't like
it yeah
hello
oh they got the car repaired damn
i did dick all in that round same mark
you scared the [ __ ] out of me like three
times
i was just having fun with it that was
super cool i i like being the monster
it's pretty fun though that's pretty fun
i feel like it has potential this is
early access right so
do the clowns give you guys no like does
the clown thing make noise the clowns
and the
teddy bears are pretty big noises for
the
yeah i had a background back and mark
walker
i couldn't see anything i don't i think
it was random but that was so cool i was
like oh [ __ ]
i can't hear anything yeah it's weird
that that's only happened to us once out
of like
six games yeah that was crazy